In 1942 the US Army Corp of Engineers started building
what is the greatest model ever made
So in 1927 America suffered what Herbert Hoover called
“the greatest peacetime calamity in the countries history"
the Great Mississippi Flood
it flooded seven states, half a million people were displaced
and it cost the country
a third of their entire federal budget at the time
but mainly it was just terrible
and so the US Army Corp of Engineers did what they do
up and down the Mississippi they built levees
and everyone was like “Cool!"
no more flooding, we tamed nature,
and then in 1937 it flooded again
because every time they built a levee somewhere
that area wouldn’t flood but a town just a few miles down
would be destroyed
they didn’t understand how the river really worked
Corporal Eugene Reybold, this guy had a genius idea
he was like “Why don’t we model it?"
And what this meant was literally
why don’t we build a gigantic model of it?
So the notion was, let’s make a scale model
a tiny version of the entire Mississippi river basin
the scale of this model is amazing
it meant building a model of 40% of the entire US
eight miles of tiny streams
It’s so big you can’t see it except from a plane or helicopter
because it’s spread out over 200 acres
the whole thing was a hydraulic model
so they could just pull a lever and run through an entire flood
and it let them put up little levees
and figure out “OK, if we put up a levee here,
what happens down the river?"
They used it to stop a flood in Omaha
and save sixty five million dollars
At the time it was also a wonder
people came to visit it
they came to stride like giants across the landscape
the Army Corp of Engineers went to the trouble
of building little buildings
and making sure all the towns had names
and so it was this kind of incredible experience
and families would come to stride across the land
you could walk from the south to the midwest in five minutes
six years after they finished it, they were done
the last test using the Mississippi River model was run
they didn’t need it anymore
they left it, they just walked away basically
and then they gave it to the city of Jackson, Mississippi
and they didn't know what to do with it
they didn’t have any money
so they have literally just left it rotting
in the middle of the park
where it is today
the Army Corp of Engineers set out to build this model
but they also made this kind of beautiful sculpture
so today the tiny little banks of the Mississippi
are slowly being overgrown with actual foliage
Click here to subscribe, click here fro more videos
and it’s just, it’s awesome
it’s so cool. it’s like an engineers disneyland
if you are ever in Jackson, it’s the thing to do
people have their little RC car competitions there
and it’s great, I will link to one of those RC car videos  at the end of this video
here, look at the, i dunno… look at this RC car video